watch the girl  I'll be fair sex out  Oh Stu that's my favorite tune I'm gonna  love ending you here even though we'll  be working on abandoned streets miles  behind the front lines i guarantee you  whatever they put us it would not be  safe this is a war zone it is likely  that will encounter both active pods and  peacekeepers you're considered high  value targets to the capital our unit  has been given a hollow a database that  contains a detailed map of the capital  and a list of every known pod these pods  can trigger anything from bombs to traps  two months whatever they contain there I  meant to kill you ladies and gentlemen  welcome to the 76th Hunger Games  you